-It is time for
our latest installment
of "Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show Polls" ♪
-Let's check out
this first poll.
This poll asked,
"If you're a parent,
how are you handling
school closings?"
50% said, "Getting my kids
set up on Zoom."
30% said, "In-person tutoring."
And 20% said, "Wine."
[ Laughter ]
That's not the only --
Surprised it's that low.
-That would do it, yeah.
-The next poll asked,
"How are you testing for COVID?"
64% said, "Using at-home
rapid tests."
32% said, "Getting a PCR
at my doctor's office."
4% said, "Shoving a Q-tip
up my nose,
rubbing it on a pregnancy test,
and hoping for the best."
[ Applause ]
-Florida.
-[ Chuckles ]
This next poll said, "What are
you watching on Netflix?"
10% said, "Queer Eye."
10% said, "Emily in Paris."
80% said, "My own reflection
while I scroll through TikTok."
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
This next one asked,
"How did you feel
after your booster shot?"
50% said, "I felt normal."
49% said,
"I felt a little achy."
The CEO of Pfizer said,
"I pfelt perpfectly pfine."
[ Laughter ]
This next one asked,
"What's the best way to make
your home entertainment system
feel like a movie theater?"
12% said, "Get a widescreen TV."
23% said,
"Buy a comfortable recliner."
65% said, "Hire a stranger
to sit next to you
and suck on a Milk Dud
too loudly."
[ Laughter, applause ]
-[ Sucking loudly ]
-[ Chuckles ]
You likin' the movie?
[ Laughter ]
-Can I have one of those?
-Sure.
-[ Imitates splattering ]
-There you go.
-I got two packs.
-[ Chuckles ]
Every time we would
go out to the movies,
my mom,
she would sneak in candy.
And it was just like
the loudest candy
you could ever sneak in
anywhere.
It was just like wrapping
and unwrapping and wrapping.
And I'd go,
"What is your thing?"
And then all of a sudden
I heard her go like...
[ Hissing ]
She had, like, a 2-liter bottle
of seltzer or something.
[ Laughter ]
"What are you doing?"
-Saving money, man.
-How do you like your burger?
-Are you cooking stuff?
-Yeah. How do you like
your burger? Medium?
-I got a fondue pot for nachos.
-[ Chuckles ]
This next poll asked, Have you
played the new game Wordle?
Isn't it so much fun?"
25% said, "M-A-Y-B-E."
25% said, "G-R-A-V-E."
25% said, "A-G-A-V-E.
25% said, "A-G-R-E-E."
Yeah, we did it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
This next poll asks, "What
rating would you give
The Weeknd's new album?"
100% said, "Tn out of tn."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a thinker kind of,
yeah.
-A thinker, not a stinker.
-The last polls asked,
"What angers you the most?"
60% said, "Politics."
39% said, "Taxes."
Elmo said,
"Rocks can't eat cookies."
There you go, everybody.
That's all we have for
"Tonight Show Polls."